hey this is presto Walker here's a
puzzle you could share with this special
person on Valentine's Day if Sigma 8d H
is equal to loan and - + 8 r pi equals
tor I then what is 128 times the square
root of e 9 80 can you figure out this
puzzle give it a quick try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
the answer so here is the pattern you
need to cover the top half of each of
the symbols and the letters to get the
resulting word Sigma 8 D H becomes loan
- + 8 R PI becomes tour I and so what
does the final line become well if we
cover up the top half we get I love you
I hope you like this puzzle and please
feel free to share it thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math and
puzzles you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check on my books and you can
support me on patreon you can also email
me at presh and mind your decisions calm
and you can catch me on social media
either at mind your decisions or a
pressure Locker